this is the coolest deep learning
machine that i have ever had the
opportunity to use
it's the most power in the smallest form
factor also that i've ever used and
finally it also runs the coolest
temperatures that i've ever used
it's the camino grando rm v2 s
it's capable of running upright like you
see here as a workstation or on its side
in a standard rack mounting solution
it's a clear competitor to the nvidia
dgx station a100 and with a look inside
we can begin to see how and why this
machine is engineered by a company
called camino that makes everything from
a tiny water cooling gaming rig called
auto for a couple thousand dollars
all the way up to mobile data centers
inside of shipping containers inside
this particular grondo rm v2 short build
there are four a 140 gigabyte pcie cards
each of which are water cooled we also
have an amd ryzen 3995 wx water cooled
cpu as well as a massive radiator to
cool these parts and we can also see the
fans for the three 750 watt power
supplies and everything exhausts out the
rear where you might also spot a
temperature sensor
this is for measuring the output air
temperatures the motherboard is an asus
pro wrx80e sage with 512 gigabytes of
rdem server grade memory
on to the front we have a view window to
our water pump along with the lcd
display showing various machine stats
like the input and output air
temperatures as well as another
temperature sensor near the camino logo
for that intake air temperature
speaking of temperatures at full 100 gpu
util for all four a100s we see max temps
at 68 degrees celsius which is just that
one literally physically the top gpu
and then lower 60 degrees celsius for
the rest
uh this test ran for about two and a
half hours and honestly i'm just
astonished at these these results that's
it's actually 10 degrees celsius cooler
than the dgx stations a100s which were
cooled with refrigerant
so that's pretty crazy now these are
different cards different machines and
because of their different cards they're
in theory different tdps so the dgx
station had the a100 sxm cards and the
80 gigabit 80 gigabyte sxm card has a
400 watt tdp
and so in theory that would be a hotter
card just because of the wattage but um
what i found on that dgx station is that
the cards seemed to run at with more
like a 250 watt tdp my guess is they
clocked this down because that entire
dgx station ran off a single plug so to
do that
uh you've got a
down something so if you have four 400
watt uh gpus that means you're already
exceeding the 1 500 watt maximum of a
single outlet which also means you've
got nothing for to actually run the
refrigerant um to run your cpu all that
stuff so anyway um i think it's a fair
comparison for the cooling and i gotta
be honest i'm really impressed i just i
i think that's the biggest takeaway for
me with these camino machines is the
custom water cooling
the the engineering here is so well done
if you're wondering how the camino
sounds while it's running
this is how it sounds it's going to get
a little louder when i take the side
panel off but what i want to talk about
is the actual cooling on the kamino
so
the way the camino is built is the
intake of air is through the front but
the um the only actual fans that dictate
that that's an intake are these three
fans right here
now when the side panels on that means
that because those fans are blowing air
this way it's going to suck air from the
front
then basically when the panel's on the
path of least resistance is going to be
through the radiator effectively
hopefully cooling the water and cooling
the gpus
but what i found interesting was when i
was doing the thermal images i basically
i run the benchmark wait till
temperatures level out i take off the
side panel and take thermal images as
quickly as possible just to get as close
to how they were
um
and what i noticed though was that since
the benchmark was still running the
temperatures of the gpus actually
dropped by like one to two degrees
and then i was like well well maybe it's
just because i took the side panel off
and you might think well obviously it's
because you took the side panel off but
the only thing cooling these gpus is the
water cooling so
with the side panel off you could
probably even hear it the microphone is
like right here in front of where this
air is blowing i can feel it it's cool
air it's not even hot air so the air
from these fans is just kind of coming
off the radiator right into me and it's
it's not hot air
so if i put my hand behind the machine i
can feel there's like hot air but
there's no air pressure coming from it
so it's almost like the radiator is just
like one giant heat sink like air is not
actually blowing through it
um but
comically enough that seems to actually
be more efficient than when the side
panel is on now there are other things
that need to be cooled and are probably
depending on air passing over them so
like on the on the motherboard like the
ram and sometimes the vrm although in
this case that motherboard seems to have
like a little be like a little fan and
heatsink so i think that's probably fine
since it was designed to have the side
panel on i'll put the panel back on but
i just thought that was really
interesting that the um
the radiator doesn't appear to need air
at least in large volume to be passing
through it and then somehow it's
actually cooler with the side panel off
and this is just a
i guess a heat sink i don't know
anyway pretty interesting
okay so it runs cool but how does it
perform well this is not the first time
that we've talked about the glory of the
a100 gpu on this channel it is indeed
the fastest gpu available right now now
first looking at the relative time chart
here what we're looking at is how
quickly can the same gpu or group of
gpus run through the same task so same
model size same data set size all that
so in this case the lower the better so
the lower just means it's run through
that task faster and so the x axis here
is in seconds so what we can see is the
a100 is 5.6 times faster than the 1080
ti it's 3.4 times faster than the rtx
8000 about 2.2 times faster than the rtx
3090
so yes it's fast one curious result that
i found was when i ran the same
benchmark on the camino that i had used
to benchmark the dgx station
so now we're looking at a tensorboard of
that benchmark and we're comparing how
quickly these a100 cards stepped over
the same amount of data in the form of
how many steps per second can that gpu
do where each step is a batch so in this
case higher is better it means you're
stepping quicker here we can see that
the 40 gigabyte pcie card in the camino
appears to be 12
faster than the sxm a100
in the dgx station and that was an sxm a
180 gigabyte card
in theory it should be
if anything a little quicker i wish i
had a dgx station lying around to do
further tests but for now it's just
something quite curious i my best guess
is it relates to the sort of down
clocking uh that the sxm cards were put
through so everything could run on that
single outlet one final way to compare
the nvidia dgx stations to this komino
machine is through envy link i never
personally paid much attention to envy
link but i have found that sometimes it
can make a massive surprising difference
specifically with large language model
tasks one of these days i plan to dig
more into envy links specifically
because sometimes it doesn't matter much
or it's very marginal and then sometimes
it really matters like we're talking
double the performance but also not all
envy links are the same with hugely
varying bandwidths so for example with
the confident benchmark the addition of
envy link does improve things it's about
a 23 to 24 improvement but i'd still say
this is fairly marginal
and again this is with a single convent
that's being trained with batches just
across multiple gpus but it's the same
model that we're training we're just
using multiple gpus to do that and again
just like before with this relative time
chart the lower the bar in this case the
better because that means it went faster
through the process now what if we look
at using transformer models where we
want to train again the same large
language model across multiple gpus so
one model multiple gpus this is where
the dgx station can basically double the
performance of the camino and to be
clear the convenient model that i just
showed you that was also one convenient
across multiple gpus it's just it was a
confident but now we're looking at a
transformer model and we're back to the
tensorboard so in this case the higher
the better because this is how many
steps per second is the machine taking
so in this case what we're looking at is
the puget machine with two rtx 3090s one
example is without the envy link and one
example is with the envy link and here
you can see the envy link is making a
massive massive difference
almost twice as fast just by throwing in
the envy link so
this is why the dgx station if you're
trying to train large language models
transformers
uh it might make more sense to get
something that is with those sxm cards
on the hdx boards because all four of
those cards are envy linked whereas on
the camino with the pcie a100 cards you
can only two-way envy link you can't
actually do a three-way or four-way envy
link so it can only be in pairs now at
least for me personally i more often
than not find myself trying to train
many models per gpu rather than multiple
gpus per model simply because you never
really know what model you're going to
use out of the gate so there's always
just a bunch of trial and error where
you're testing many different model
types so for the r d process i think
it's kind of a wash but for sure when i
was trying to train for example gpt
medium on python code for example using
that dgx station was really nice and i
really did need to use all four of those
uh a100 gpus so it is something that you
want to keep in mind the form factor of
the camino is also pretty impressive on
the right i have an air cooled box
machine with two rtx 8000s and on the
left i've got an air-cooled puget with
the two rtx 3090s
the kamino is basically the size of the
box just a little bit longer which makes
sense they're both rack mountable and
the puget is an atx xl size and it
honestly just looks like a giant next to
the camino but the kamino is more
powerful than the puget and the box put
together
also the dgx station was a atx xl size
so this tiny form factor for the 4x a100
build from kamino
really is impressive especially given
the temperatures that it runs at
so i think for me the trait that i find
most impressive here is just kamino's
ability to pack an abundance of
performance into
a relatively tiny form factor and the
reason that they can do this is because
of the water cooling and honestly being
willing to sort of rethink case design
and engineering because this casing
supports
all the way up to eatx motherboards as
big as they get
but it still has this pretty small form
factor it's such a unique build and at
least for me personally i
love the design i just love the way this
unit looks
very often we and i build computers and
slap on some rgb ram or fans or
something like that to make it look cool
but camino has just engineered cool here
there is just something about this
machine that i just love it
on the topic of cool i also recently
moved my operations to a far more uh and
better air conditioned area
so no longer am i breaking a sweat when
the machines are running
and the running temperatures of the
kamino under load are even better uh in
the 50s
again that's at full load
again i would love to see what the dgx
station runs in this same space but such
as life i don't have one lying around so
the price of this specific build comes
in at a pretty significant 72 000
most of which is just the price of the
a100 gpus this is something like 45 to
50 thousand dollars just in
gpus and that cpu is about six thousand
dollars the rdem ram is also a pretty
penny
this build is meant to be compared to
something like the 100 000
4x a100 40 gigabyte dji station uh and i
think it compares
pretty well you could definitely get a
camino grondo rm short build for a
fraction of this cost by simply going
with different gpus and cpu or of course
you could go bigger with six gpus or
even a shipping container data center
i'm also curious about things like auto
just other completely custom and unique
water cooled small design
at least relatively tiny designs for
gaming and data science and all that and
just in general i'm excited to see what
else this company comes up with over
time and i'm honored to have had the
time to spend with the camino
i do have to unfortunately send it back
eventually but daniel and i do have some
plans for it first stay tuned
you